[Music]
we have a ton like millions and millions
and millions of you listening that have
come to us in the last 18 months or so a
lot of new folks have joined the tribe
in the last little while so let me kind
of walk you through after doing this for
25 years here on the air and working
with you one of the things I have
learned to do I didn't I don't always do
it right but I've learned to do is
listen to what you're not saying or what
so to speak reading between the lines
the hebrew word called Shama and that
when you're reading scriptures the
question behind the question the problem
behind the problem the opportunity
behind the opportunity there's a thing
that happens when to your language the
Bible says how the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks so the the words
that you use even your sentence
structure reveals oftentimes what's
going on in our lives me too in our laps
whether we're feeling optimistic or
angry or afraid whether we are having
the best time of our life or the worst
time of our life we're terrified
sometimes people being on the air here
it may a caller they're nervous we've
never lost a patient but sometimes it's
an it's natural to be nervous to be on
the radio in front of 15 million people
I mean that's natural but one thing that
you can watch for in your own speech is
when you are describing your life your
situation your financial position your
career position when you start making
broad statements as absolute dogmatic
fact
and I'll give you some examples you can
tell that the situation is no longer the
problem the way you're looking at the
situation is the problem here's an
example Dave know what there are no
rental properties in our city under X
$1,500 a month I have to get a rental
property that's $15 a month you don't
understand our city there is no such
thing as a rental property these
absolute statements under $1500 a month
I have to pay $1500 a month you just
don't understand that's what it costs to
live here there's no rental properties
under $59 a month see when you make a
statement like that you are not making
an accurate statement about your area
you're making a statement about your
view of your area and somehow you're
wanting to get a pass on math and you're
saying well I'm stuck and so I'm just
gonna go ahead and be stupid people like
me can't get ahead and you're doing a
glass half for half-empty kind of thing
you're being a pessimist instead of an
optimist and in philosophical terms
you've become a fatalist
well like you just you don't understand
the only way yeah I'm gonna be you want
me to be homeless
it's either homeless or $1,500 and
that's a fatalistic viewpoint it's also
wrong it's stupid because everybody
listening and that's that lives in that
city knows that you can find something
under $1500 in the city right so when
you make a fatalistic absolute dogmatic
statement like that it what it really
means is your spirit is reaching
hopelessness you're feeling stuck it
doesn't mean there aren't any rental
properties that you can get find you
move a little bit further out of town
you can leave in a different area than
you want to live in maybe in that town
but you can always find something to
rent different than that you can always
do different and that's why I was
jumping on her case a minute ago the
lady that called from Jacksonville
Florida young lady everyone in
Jacksonville Florida
that is hiring information technology
requires five years experience to which
my mind immediately says well that's
absolutely not true
that is just not true that's that's what
you've been told and you've been beat up
and rejected a lot but that's just
simply not true is there is there
another way to get at your job look okay
but you know there's not a single
company out of what what is Jacksonville
to three million people you know there's
not a single company has ever hired
anyone with a four-year degree in
information technology without
experience that's absurd
it's just ridiculous
now that doesn't mean she's ridiculous
but what that says is her spirit in that
situation she's just I don't know what's
happening whether she's putting in
applications getting rejected her job
hunt process is wrong she's not been
able to get her foot in the door I
didn't have time to give her full career
counseling and all that but I'm not
picking on her I'm just teaching you
when you start using statements like
that no one in our town loses a property
for under $1,500 no one in this city of
three million people has however hired
an IT person without experience that's
just ridiculous no one has ever hired a
person that's bald no one has ever
gotten married that was overweight you
know I don't know that's just bull you
know I mean you know but that's just
these are absent when you hear yourself
turn into a drama queen like that or
drama king like that that says there's
something going on inside of you it's
not reflective of the situation because
of the absurdity of your statement and
so what I'm teaching you is this I'm not
picking on her what I'm teaching you is
I do that to I've done it to it but when
you go to an absolute fatalistic
position like that in drama queen mode
what you're doing is you're slipping off
into the land of victim I'm a victim cuz
no cuz you just can't get ahead here
little man can't get it here you don't
know about the isms the sexism x' and
the racism x' and the
republicanism x' and the democrat isms
and the bald isms and the fat people
isms and you don't know about all the
isms isms will hold you back
theirs will hold you back they do racism
is real it's out there there's some
jerks out there sexism is real some
people don't think women are as smart as
men and these are really dumb people you
know i mean it's it's real it's a
reality but do you meet people that make
it in spite of that yep in spite of
their ISM I got a hillbilly ISM I'm a
hillbilly so you know it's really
difficult to get some radio people in
the Northeast to treat people with a
southern accent as if they're
intelligent they think we're operating
this thing out of a double-wide
because I have a southern accent it's a
stereotype
you know I'm worth several hundred
million dollars we have 700 employees
here the company does 200 million
dollars a year in volume but we're we're
not real smart over here in the South
you know isms are real people
you got to overcome them anyway you got
to go win anyway you can't slip off into
oil you can't you know nobody in the
Northeast will carry a southern guy on
the radio well some people won't that's
right but they're the ones that are
missing out on all the revenue I'm
producing for their competitors and I
just go up there and win anyway we go
into California and win anyway with our
little southern charm hello we go win
anyway is it hard yeah it's hard but I'm
not gonna assume victim status and start
making drama queen statements that are
fatalistic be careful what you're saying
with your mouth it reflects the
condition of your spirit have the spirit
of a Victoire not a victim this is the
Dave Ramsey show